the left embraces socialism eugenics in
revolution president Trump attacks Chuck
Todd and Maxine Waters
and OJ's back which is weird I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so the left went crazy over the weekend
so no Disneyland for them there was
Disneyland for me however but there will
be no Disneyland for them because the
weekend was a very weird time on the
op-ed pages of our nation's leading
newspapers I'll tell you all about all
the crazy that was happening but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zip recruiter so every business
needs better people in fact we need
better people right now on the show I
mean just generally but that's why if we
were to replace them we would be using
zip recruiters zip recruiter learns what
you're looking for and identifies people
with the right experience and invites
them to apply to a job that you need
filled they built a platform that finds
the right job candidates for you 80% of
employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day and zip
recruit does not stop there they even
spotlight the strongest applicants you
receive so you never miss a great match
the right candidates are out there and
zip recruiter is how you find them right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free that's right for free at zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear again
when you use that slash daily wire you
can now try zip recruiter for free can
post a job and your inbox will start
filling with resumes right away and you
can cultivate those resumes right there
in the zipper career app instead of
having to download it to your email and
deal with their zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wear if you want the best
employees all you need to do is go to
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire and
they will take care of it for you and
right now as they say you can post jobs
for free 80% of employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate in
just one day so check it out zip
recruiters comm slash daily wire it is
the smartest way to hire ok so over the
weekend the nation's op-ed pages decided
to remind us all why president rump is
president not because he's so great at
everything not because the president is
a playing Magne Magne Magne chess but
because the left has decided to go fully
crazy
there are several stop ads in a row that
we're gonna go through here talking
about the the outskirts of the left but
these are printed in mainstream
newspapers again this is not stuff from
the nation this is not stuff even from
salon or slate this is stuff from the
New York Times and The Washington Post
and the Atlantic all of these are
mainstream outlets on the left and none
of them are particularly good I don't
know what was in the water over the
weekend or whether they just feel so
emboldened on the left that they feel
like they can have sand and they can say
anything and get away with it but
whatever it is it is not it is not gonna
be good for their agenda here
the first example Ruth Marcus he's the
deputy editorial page editor it's jazz a
high position over at the Washington
Post wrote in an opinion piece called
quote I would have aborted a fetus with
Down syndrome women need that right ok
this is just a piece in favor of
eugenics if the idea is that you get to
abort a baby because the baby has Down
syndrome then what is the difference
between aborting a baby with Down
syndrome not because you don't think
it's a baby but because it has Down
syndrome and doing that with somebody
who is actually already born here's a
ruth marcus writes there's a new push
and anti-abortion circles to pass state
laws aimed at bar and women from
terminating their pregnancy after the
fetus has been determined to have Down
syndrome these laws are unconstitutional
unenforceable and wrong this is a
difficult subject to discuss because
there are so many parents who have in
cherish a child with Down syndrome many
people with Down syndrome live happy and
fulfilled wives the new Gerber baby with
Down syndrome is awfully cute I've had
two children I was old enough when I
became pregnant that it made sense to do
the testing for Down syndrome back then
it was amniocentesis performed after 15
weeks now Creon chorionic villus
sampling can provide a conclusive
determination as early as nine weeks I
can say without hesitation the tragic as
it would have been in gas lease that
second trimester abortion would have
been I would have terminated those
pregnancies had the testing come back
positive I would have grieved the loss
and moved on well good for you Ruth that
you would have grieved the loss first of
all it's always a bizarre point in in
abortion fanatics lingo that they'll say
things like I would have grieved the
loss and the loss of what if it's not
morally wrong then what are you grieving
if it's just a cluster of cells then
what exactly are you grieving are
grieving the lost opportunity like well
what are you presumably you're grieving
the human that you just killed or had
killed in the womb and just because that
human in the womb had Down syndrome
doesn't mean that it was okay for you to
do that you should feel morally
exculpated from what you just did here's
what she continues to say I'm not alone
more than two-thirds of American women
choose abortion in such circumstances
isn't that the point or at least
inherent in the point of prenatal
testing in the first place well no the
points of prenatal testing in the first
place is generally to see if there is
some sort of condition that can be fixed
as the pregnancy continues so for
example if there had been the capacity
to actually look at my child's my first
child's heart and see that there was a
hole in her heart when she was
developing they might have been able to
do something prenatally I don't know how
the surgery works but there are all
sorts of surgeries that they do on
children before they are born where they
actually performance an amazing thing
they perform surgeries on children who
are still in the womb and they show up
to a woman
the pregnancy continues and the kid is
just fine this sort of thing happens all
the time the point of prenatal testing
is not kill the child if things come out
wrong that's called eugenics folks okay
and say bad thing this is what they have
in Iceland Down syndrome people are not
there and I like they just don't exist
in Iceland because they're all killed in
the womb that is not a good thing for
the inherent value of human life when
you say the inherent value of human life
degrades if you are born with with low
IQ thanks to genetic conditions if you
believe that abortion is equivalent to
murder the taking of the human life then
of course you would make it a different
choice but that is not my belief and the
Supreme Court has affirmed my freedom to
have that belief and act accordingly
well you can always have that belief I
mean you they give the freedom to have
that belief but the Supreme Court is not
a moral arbiter this is one of the
things that drives pro-life people
absolutely insane when people look at
pro-choice people and pro-choice people
point to the Supreme Court they point
like justice Blackmun I said well
justice Blackmun says it's okay my
answer does who the hell is justice
blackmun why would I care about that
like Ruth Bader Ginsburg says something
is okay ooh-hoo-hoo-hoo now you've
spooked me wow you totally changed my
opinion now I guess it wasn't a human
life because justice roberts said
something or because justice kennedy
said something is so dumb and final it's
an argument from Authority the same
people say you can't cite the Bible in
defense of human life we'll say you can
say Ruth Bader Ginsburg in defense of
the right to kill a human life pretty
amazing stuff Ruth Marcus says I respect
I admire families that knowingly welcome
a baby with Down syndrome into their
lives again the sentiments here are
conflicting why do you respect and
admire those people presumably you think
those people made a horrible mistake
presumably you think those people are
idiots who think that this was a human
life it wasn't a human life and now they
brought a child into the world and that
child is presumably suffering because of
it down syndrome so presumably they're
bad people for bringing the child into
the world like this is not a lot there's
not a lot of gray area here she says
certainly to be a parent is to take the
risks that accompany parenting you love
your child for who she is not what you
want her to be but accepting that
essential truth is different from
compelling a woman to give birth to a
child whose intellectual capacity will
be impaired whose life choices will be
limited whose health may be compromised
okay let me read that sentence again
okay very slowly for those who missed it
that's an insane sentence a fully crazy
that is a morally that is a morally
ignominious statement accepting that
essential truth is different from
compelling a woman to give birth to a
child whose intellectual capacity
be impaired okay every single person in
the United States has an impaired
intellectual capacity to one extent or
another everyone is not born Einstein
has a very small group of people who are
born with genius-level IQ everybody else
does not have as much of a chance in
life does that mean that abortion is
okay I mean this is pure eugenics right
here whose life choices will be limited
hey every single human has life choices
that are limited every single human hey
you what what you're looking for when
you're talking about morality is a
limiting principle you're looking for
something that distinguishes cases if
this says as we say in law school would
be an argument that proves too much it
suggests that every human being should
be aborted based on certain
circumstances whose life choices will be
limited okay Beethoven was born into a
family where his dad used to beat him in
the middle of the night if he didn't
practice piano correctly was that a
limited life choice sure he went deaf
later in life when we were actually not
even that late when he was in his late
20s he started to go deaf was that a
limited life choice sure right whose
health may be compromised every single
person will die every person who's been
born will die and everyone will have a
health problem before then says most
children with Down syndrome have mild to
moderate cognitive impairment being an
IQ between 55 and 70 mild or between 35
and 55 moderate this means limited
capacity for independent living in
financial security Down syndrome is
life-altering for the entire family now
there's no question that that is true
but that is also true when you have a
parent who's slipping into senility do
we get to stab them in the chest
do we farm them off to the soil and
Green Factory then when people get
Alzheimer's what are we supposed to do
with them is the idea that the the good
thing for the family would be just to
pull the plug there are tons of people
whose capacity for independent living is
limited and who celui lived wonderful
lives and not only that sometimes it
makes you a better person as you can
make me we're talking about the impact
on the mother here sometimes it makes us
as human beings better that we have to
make certain sacrifices in favor of
others when I was growing up my dad had
a pretty debilitating back condition he
meant that everybody in the family had
to carry all heavy objects around the
house Riley my dad just couldn't carry
it wasn't a thing and we just grew up
knowing that was something that we had
to do now obviously that's very mild
compared to what we're talking about
here but the point is this love is about
the sacrifices that you make for the
people that you love and when it comes
to when it comes to people with Down
syndrome are they not deserving of love
in the same way that anybody else would
be whose Markinson
one tear this was not the child I wanted
that was not the choice I would have
made you make homie selfish or worse but
I am in good company
well no you're in bad company actually I
knew our selfish or worse she says the
evidence is cleared the most women
confronted with the same unhappy
alternative would make the same decision
again a horrifying argument lots of
people make horrible decisions
throughout the course of human history
and Nazi Germany tons of people were
making terrible decisions all the time
and then they would say the majority is
with me guess what the majority in the
south was with segregation and slavery
did that mean segregation and slavery
were okay of course not that's not even
an argument that's an emotional appeal
well don't talk about me like I'm
special I'm not special everybody else
is bad too
this crap doesn't work with my
kindergartner my pre kindergartner
shouldn't work with a fully grown woman
says which brings us to the Supreme
Court North Dakota Ohio Indiana and
Louisiana passed legislation to prohibit
doctors from performing abortions if the
sole reason is because of a diagnosis of
Down syndrome Utah's legislature is
debating such a bill these laws are
flatly inconsistent with the Supreme
Court's roe v wade ruling reaffirmed in
1992 the quoted is a constitutional
liberty of the woman to have some
freedom to terminate her pregnancy well
not really the issue if you puts the
focus on the phrase of the woman but the
focus should be on some freedom even if
you are believer in roe v wade there is
some freedom but that freedom does not
extend to everything he says as US
District Judge Tanya Walton Pratt
concluded in striking down the Indiana
law the state's High Court determination
leaves no room for the state to examine
let alone prohibit the basis or basis
upon which a woman makes her choice so
for any reason abortion on dimensions
think about it can it be the women have
more constitutional freedom to choose to
terminate the pregnancies on a whim than
for the reason that the fetus has down
syndrom now this is her only good
argument and proves the reverse of what
she wants it to prove she's saying well
why would we limit the capacity of women
to choose on Down syndrome but we
wouldn't limit their capacity to choose
to abort a fetus just for fun
I agree agree okay the fact is that when
you are talking about killing a baby in
the womb your choice should be severely
circumscribed whether you're talking
about Down syndrome or anything else and
she says to the question of
enforceability who's gonna police the
decision-making doctors are now supposed
to turn in their patients for making a
decision of which the state disapproves
no my guess is that all of these bills
do not punish the woman they probably
punish the doctor they say in an
argument worthy of this Ruth Marcus in
an argument worthy of The Handmaid's
Tale from the state of Indiana suggests
precisely that's an air
the right to abortion it's lawyer argued
before a federal appeals court last
month protects only the binary decision
of whether to bear a child not which
child you must carry to term once you
choose to become pregnant
in other words though they didn't put
the we didn't put it in these exact
words the state can hijack your body
it's not about hijacking the body of the
woman this is about protecting the body
of the baby inside the woman duh okay so
this is just example number one of the
extremism of the left brought into full
relief we'll get to another crazy
example in just a second the dumbest
column in recent history that one
doesn't even take the cake for the
weekend hey first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at bull and branch
so over the weekend we all lost an hour
of sleep yeah I know it was terrible but
if you are trying to regain that hour of
sleep if you are looking for the most
comfortable the most comfortable sheets
that you can sleep on that is bull and
branch the bull and branch cheats are
fantastic they're so good then I throw
out all of our old sheets and I got only
Boleyn branch eats because they are that
good the reason they are that good is
they are made from a pure 100% organic
cotton they start out very soft and they
get even softer over time they are
incredibly breathable so you don't feel
like you're sleeping in a tarp you can
buy directly from Boleyn branch so you
are essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to $1,000 in
the store Boleyn brand sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks which may sound
expensive except for the fact that
you're going to sleep on these every
night of your life and it makes a huge
difference in how you sleep I promise
you it does for me it does for my wife
these sheets are so comfortable everyone
who tries Boleyn brand sheets loves them
including me three u.s. presidents and
Bill Clinton's presumed lovers sleep on
bull and branch sheets shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to send
them back because they really are
fantastic to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull at bull and branch
comp remote Club n that's Bo LLM branch
com promo Club Band to get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets bull and branch
comm promo code then check that out
using that promo code Ben lets them know
that we sent you and of course $50 not
for first set of sheets they are the
most comfortable sheets you have ever
slept on bar none it is not close okay
so now it's time for crazy editorial
number two so again you wonder why
Trump wins you want around Republicans
win even though they are really bad at
everything and why is it the Republicans
keep winning even though they're really
bad at everything it's because the left
has gone crazy now there are a couple of
charts out there that show the
Democratic and Republican Party splits
meaning where the right has moved in
where the left is moving what the
our show is that basically since 2010
the Republican Party has been static but
the Democratic Party has been moving
wildly left
they've moving solely to the left so the
greater Parliament partisan polar gap
that's being created right now is being
created by the left moving hard to the
left not by the right moving harder to
the right okay so with that in mind here
is crazy column at number two so this
one is courtesy of some weird guy named
Tim Crider over at the New York Times
he's an essayist he's a professional
essayist which is to say he reads a
bunch of stuff the New York Times pays
him for but the only people who read him
are people who sit there with their cat
and their cup of coffee at brunch on
Sunday morning on the Upper East Side of
Manhattan he penned an op-ed that is I
mean this is a crazy op-ed it's called
go ahead Millennials destroy us no I am
not kidding that is the name of the
op-ed and it is not a good at
shockingly you may have thought that
from that title it would be a great on
it is in fact a terrible op-ed so let's
go through how bad this op-ed is okay
this happened apparently came out I
guess March 2nd 2018 so it's a little
bit old but it's still it's still worth
commenting on so it's over the last week
and a half he says as with all the
historic tipping points it seems
inevitable in retrospect of course it
was young people the actual victims of
the slaughter will finally begun to turn
the tide against guns in this country
kids don't have money and can't vote and
until now burying a few dozen a year has
apparently been a price that lots of
Americans were willing to pay to hold on
to the props of their pathetic
role-playing fantasies but they forgot
what the adults always forget that our
children grow up and remember everything
and forgive nothing and then you just
get a weird eerie cue from children of
the corn it's all weird it's okay so
let's point something out this whole
idea that children are going to lead us
is incredibly stupid we don't listen to
children on anything and that people
will say about me well you know you were
writing a syndicated column when you
were 17 right and I was getting shellac
for the stuff that I was saying
sometimes deservedly so
I don't believe everything that I wrote
at 17 because no one does and if you do
is because you've lost the capacity to
change and the capacity to think as we
get older we have more life experience
and very often that means we get wiser
the notion that a bunch of Americans are
sitting around completely blase about
the murder of schoolchildren in parkland
Florida is just insane and then a bunch
of kids realize that their parents don't
care about them well that seems
stupid to me anyway Crider writes those
kids have suddenly understood how little
their lives were ever worth to the
people in power and they'll soon begin
to realize how efficient and endless are
the mechanisms of governance intended to
deflect their appeals exhaust their
energy deplete their passion and defeat
them but anyone who has ever tried to
argue with adolescents knows that in the
end they'll have a thousand times more
energy for that fight than you and a
bottomless reservoir of moral rage that
you burned out long ago
so Tim kryder's basically the hippie
homeless guy who hangs out outside the
store and gives kids money to buy him
beer and then all the kids think oh that
guy's cool cuz he also gave me a beer
hey you bought that got him a 6-pack
inside and then he and then sorry it's
the reverse he's the creepy guy that
he's a creepy homeless guy the kids give
money to to buy beer and then he brings
out the six-pack and he gives a 6-pack
to the kids right that's who this guy is
right I smoked doobies with the kids and
then and the uncle at the BBQ and I give
the kids beer and then I pat their back
while they vomit into the bushes and
later their mom and dad say stay away
from Uncle Jim right that's who this guy
Tim crater is because this is ridiculous
that sentence again have you ever tried
to argue with adolescents they have a
thousand times more energy for the fight
than you and a bottomless reservoir of
moral rage yeah usually they're arguing
in favor of having drugs into of taking
drugs and having random sex with people
and playing xbox instead of doing their
homework that's usually what teenagers
are arguing in favor of but we're
supposed to care about their bottomless
reservoir of moral rage honest to God if
sixteen year olds ran the world the
world would be even worse than it is
right now okay so I'm gonna talk a
little bit more about this column
because it gets even more insane than
that in just a second first well
actually you know let's just keep going
with that okay fine so here is so so he
continues like most people in middle age
I regard young people with suspicion the
young and the young at mind tend to be
uncompromising absolutist they haven't
yet faced life's heartless compromises
in forfeitures its countless trials by
board of an ethical Kobayashi Maru z' or
globally watched themselves do
everything they ever disapproved of I'm
creeped out by the increasing dogmatism
and intolerance of Millennials on the
left I felt a generational divide opened
up under me last year when everyone
under 40 seemed to agree that Dana
Schutz his painting of Emmett Till in
his coffin should be removed from the
Whitney Biennial
when I was young it seemed the natural
order of things that conservatives were
the prudes in schools who wanted books
banned and exhibitions closed while we
liberals got to be the gadflies an
iconic class I know that whenever you
disapprove of young people you're in the
wrong because you're gonna die and
they'll get to write his
but I just can't help noticing that the
liberal side isn't much fun to be on
anymore
yet right so he acknowledges the people
on the left a lot of folks on the Left
are not particularly tolerant but then
he continues yet this uprising of the
young against the ossified monolithic
power of the NRA has reminded me that
the flaws of youth it's ignorance and
naivete and passionate Maneki and
idealism are also its strengths ok so
the fact that kids are dumb and
Manichaean that they see things in black
and white that's that's that's a
strength you see young people have only
just learned that the world is an unfair
hierarchy of cruelty and greed and it's
still shocked and outrages them they
don't understand how vast and
intractable the forces that have shaped
this world really are and still think
they can change it revolutions have
always been driven by the young that's
true and most revolutions end in chaos
and bloody murder most revolutions
driven by young people and in absolute
chaos bloody murder
sometimes the murder of hundreds of
millions of people in the case of
communist revolutions in the case of the
French Revolution the end with the
guillotine they always eat the old
fogies who think that they're egging on
the young and Robespierre ends up on the
guillotine just the same as the as the
anti Jacobins who ended up on the jiajia
team because of Robespierre hey the
revolutions that have done pretty well
in human history tend not to be led by
people who are 17 hey there was a
disproportionate support for the Nazi
Party among the young the revolutions
that tend to do pretty well I'm talking
here particular bout the American
Revolution are led by middle-aged people
the average age of the Declaration of
Independence Tiny's or signers rather
was 44 that was the average age of the
people signing the Declaration of
Independence and about a dozen people
who sign who are under the age of 35 but
life expectancy in those days was also a
lot lower okay which is why the
presidential age of limitation is at 35
because the idea was that you are a
mature human being by 35 even a 17 year
old in 1776 was probably the equivalent
of 25 year old today in terms of
maturity and responsibility but this guy
Tim Crider at the New York Times he says
ever since Columbine almost 20 years ago
I've absorbed the news of more mass
shootings than I can count with an
ulcerating rage that gradually scabbed
over into a deadening cynicism so those
of us who have lived with the certain
grim realities our whole adult lives the
widening moat between the rich and the
rest of us the sclerotic influence of
money on politics the NRA is
unassailable coalition of greed and fear
they seem like facts of life as
unalterable as death itself now do you
get the feeling the Tim crater has an
agenda here you might have an agenda he
only likes young people who
with that agenda so as I mentioned
they're a bunch of young students who
actually don't agree with that agenda in
fact by-polls
young people tend to be more in favor of
gun rights than older people young
people people who are below the age of
25 tend to be more in favor of concealed
carry than older people but my favorite
thing here is he gets to the end of this
ridiculous essay and and he starts
basically he starts basically lobbying
for the young people to listen to him
and then to build a statue of him some
creator of the newer time he says the
students of parkland are like veterans
coming home from the bloody front of the
NRA Stu facto children again I'm
getting very very sick of the notion
that everybody who is in favor of gun
rights is responsible for parkland it's
like right after JFK's assassination
when the entire left decided that it was
a bunch of southern Republican rednecks
who had shot JFK even those communists
this is a complete miss Reid and we now
have news that the Parkland shooter was
reporting to the authorities he's
reporting to his teachers that he was
having dreams of shooting his fellow
students and walking around dipped in
their blood and the schools knew about
it and they did nothing about it
and there's a report from real clear
investigations last week showing that
the Broward County Schools had
implemented new policies that were
specifically designed to prevent the
reporting of kids who are involved in
misdemeanor crimes because they wanted
to lower their crime stats and it's the
NRA is fault
but anyway Tim Crider finishes up he
says my message as an aging generation
Xer to Millennials and those coming
after that is go get us take us down all
those cringing provincials who still
think climate changes the hoax that
being transgender is a fad or that
socialism means purges and re-education
camps rid the world of all of our
outmoded opinions vestigial prejudices
and rotten institutions gender roles as
disfiguring as foot-binding
the more abundant vampiric two-party
system the Savage theory of capitalism
rip it all to the ground I for one can't
wait till we're gone I just wish I could
live to see the world without us oh my
god uh just go away dude yeah first of
all I like when he says take us down and
then he says I don't mean me I mean
everyone else I mean not only me I mean
all those crazy Republican conservatives
who think things like socialism is bad
and like sex there's such things
biological sex and that maybe we
shouldn't have the government run all of
our industries there's a climate change
it's truly amazing but this is the
virtua signalling that's going on on the
left I mean that those that my goodness
gender roles is disfiguring his
foot-binding
okay no one thinks that women are being
foot bound in Western society
okay the savage theory of capitalism
that allows Tim Crider to write his
crappy columns rather than mopping up a
stall with his discarded drafts as he
probably should be doing that discarded
the area of capitalism is the only thing
that separates Tim Crider from absolute
penury in poverty considering the
quality of his work okay we'll get to
even worse okay so the editorial pages
get even worse over the weekend and I
will explain why in just second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at USC CA so are you sick of
listening to idiots like Tim Crider talk
about why you law-abiding citizen would
like a gun you know he thinks you want
to go in because you want to shoot
schoolchildren turns out you want to
protect your school children from bad
people which is why you want a gun gonna
protect your home you want to protect
your family you wanna protect your
freedom well good news for you there's
an organization called the u.s. CCA the
u.s. concealed carry Association and
right now they are giving you your
absolute last chance to make your gun
dreams come true the u.s. CC is giving
ten of you my lucky listeners $1500 to
buy an expensive new Kimber 1911 ten of
you will take home at fifteen hundred
bucks to buy one of the finest handguns
in the world obviously you'll go through
the legal background checks because
you're a law-abiding citizen it is
completely free your chances to win and
this week there will be no guns
next week simply go to defend my family
now one com defend my family now one com
instantly lock in your 10 free chances
to win right now it is that simple and
turn seconds it is 100% free you're
almost out of time the u.s. CCA is
drawing ten winners get your name on the
winners list right now head over to
defend my family now one calm let's
defend my family now one calm to enter
before it's too late
don't miss the free gun that can keep
your family safe and by the way put a
thumb in the eye of people at Tim crater
at the same time defend my family now
1.com walk in those chances defend my
family now one calm and you have ten
chances as well biting American citizens
to exercise your Second Amendment rights
by winning an expensive a new Kimber
1911 defend my family now 1.com defend
my family now one.com okay
so meanwhile so we've had the left
advocating for full-scale revolution to
rip down capitalism and gender roles we
have had the left advocating in favor of
eugenics of killing Down syndrome babies
in the womb and now we have a leftist
named named
Elizabeth Bruning who is advocating for
socialism so last week as we talked
about at length she wrote an entire
column advocating for socialism she
talked about how capitalism was deeply
flawed and terrible and we have to
ensure that socialism has another chance
and I sort of took that column apart
here on the program I also wrote a piece
about it and she was very angry that I
wrote a piece about it but actually she
got very mad that I wrote a piece in
response to all of that and what she was
particularly mad about is that I pointed
out that Venezuela Cuba Soviet Union
North Korea China these are not good
countries to live these are terrible
places and that socialism has a pretty
long and bloody history and I also
pointed out you didn't like this
particularly that a lot of the Nordic
countries a lot of the Scandinavian
countries you know all the ugly supposed
socialist paradises
are in fact largely either mercantilist
meaning state-sponsored capitalism or
fully capitalist systems with heavy
redistribution ISM if you're a socialist
society that is basically two things
that is full state ownership of the
distribution of resources and which
means full state ownership of the means
of production those are the two general
principles of socialism that the state
owns the distribution of resources and
also that the state owns the means of
production so the state decides how much
people are paid the state decides what
resources you get the state
redistributes as it sees fit so a lot of
Scandinavian countries have a lot of
redistribution isms they've won half of
socialism but most of them have also
heavy structures of private ownership
which is true in Denmark it is true in
Sweden these are actually good places to
do business if anything then we're
mercantilist than they are socialist
because these are not places where they
are redistributing all resources
inwardly they're not nationalizing every
industry instead they are sponsoring and
subsidizing particular private
industries in large ways again that's
that's fairly typical of these Nordic
systems so she's back and she's mad so
first she starts off her column today
talking about how I was mean to her
about how I strawman her she says that I
was arguing in bad faith and then she
gives a two paragraph long description
of what it means to argue in bad faith
which is idiotic because I was not
arguing in bad faith in fact I think
that her column was just bad right and
it wasn't that it wasn't that I was
faking it it wasn't that I was trying to
create a straw man I just think her
original column was bad she was
particularly mad and I mentioned Cuba
Soviet Union in Venezuela because she
says how dare you suggest that I want
America to become those places well I
never
adjusted that you actually wanted
America to become those places you
didn't mention any countries in your
column you just said capitalism as bad
and socialism is good which means that I
should probably examine some of the
socialist countries that are out there
here's what she writes sure it's last
week I wrote a column arguing the
liberals concerned about ongoing
failures in the American experiment
should consider socialist remedies
that's not what you wrote okay what she
actually wrote is the capitalism was bad
what she actually wrote the direct quote
from her piece is that capitalism itself
was inherently flawed she wrote quote
capitalism itself was soul-sucking quote
capitalism seems to be at odds with
harmonious peaceful stable liberalism of
mid-century dreams it's a direct quote
if that's not some aspects of capitalism
that's not we should keep capitalism but
we should have a socialized health care
system that's capitalism itself should
be discarded in favor of socialism so
she says last weekend wrote a column
arguing that liberals concerned about
ongoing failures in the American
experiment should consider socialist
remedies again now she wrote said I knew
there would be quite a bit of
disagreement and I knew that most though
crucially not all of it wouldn't fold in
bad faith in the case of my column this
meant many interlocutors taking
socialism to mean something along the
lines of Soviet Communism or the
Venezuelan system genna's genocides
calamities disasters and all I don't
think anybody actually believes I'm
rooting for totalitarian forms of
socialism nor for its most devastatingly
ill-mannered variants I said I wasn't
after all if one genuinely thought a
person was campaigning for genocide well
and surely wouldn't engage with someone
too unreasonable okay now she's arguing
that I set up a straw man and reading
her entire column on air which I did
last week no this is a straw man no one
claimed that Elizabeth Brunning wants a
bunch of communist genocides to occur
all over the world but I am saying that
if you are talking about socialism and
some things have unintended side effects
and socialism is one of those things it
would be kind of ridiculous to ignore
the results of socialist experiments
elsewhere just because you didn't like
the results is called the no true
Scotsman fallacy he gets a claim that it
wasn't truly socialism because bad crap
happened after it no it was truly
socialism and bad crap happened after it
they she may not have intended for the
citizens of I doubt that she or anyone
else intended for the starving citizens
of Venezuela to be eating dog right now
but they are okay even if they didn't
intend it to be I doubt that who go
Chavez wanted his citizens shooting dogs
in the streets and eating them but
that's what they're doing okay because
that's what socialism brings okay so
then she gets me
because I mentioned that some of these
supposedly socialist paradises in Nordic
countries are not actually particularly
socialist he says I also suspect my
critics knew I wasn't recommending the
United States to go Khmer Rouge based on
my particular theme they kept returning
to Scandinavia I hadn't named the Nordic
countries in my piece but my opponents
were quick to discard them from the
conversation so let me get this straight
it's wrong for me to mention Venezuela
and Cuba and it's also wrong for me to
mention the Nordic countries so which is
it am I allowed to mention like any
countries that you claim are socialist
or no is there no cup no country is
socialist except in Elizabeth burnings
mind says after all these countries are
inconvenient when arguing that socialism
necessarily means mass murder and famine
and then she quotes me saying no Sweden
and Denmark aren't socialist countries
and she says the daily where's ben
shapiro noted apropos of nothing in his
piece on my alleged Stalinism well no
actually I'm dismissing them as
socialist countries because if you're
gonna talk about true socialism you
should talk about true socialism not
capitalist countries with some
redistributionist tendencies the United
States is a capitalist country with
redistributionist tendencies he says
it's the kind of pre-emptive rebuttal
once applies when one knows what their
opponent means but rather spend time
attacking something else
well no I'm happy to discuss the
socialism and the supposed socialism of
these countries and then what's funny is
that brooding doesn't really discuss
Sweden or Denmark right she ignores
Sweden in Denmark the two examples that
I picked in which Bernie Sanders usually
uses right when he talks about socialism
instead she chooses Norway so let's talk
about Norway is the only podcast today
we're gonna hear lots of stuff about
Norway they're gonna hear lots of stuff
about Norway not just because they're
really good in Winter Olympic sports but
also because they're a favorite of the
left when the left is arguing in favor
of socialism so here's what she says
about Norway well first at first she
says that she says first I think it
makes sense to think of social as amount
of spectrum sort of like gender right
it's like it's a spectrum with some
countries and policies being more or
less socialist rather than either/or
it's fair to say for example the sink
repair a single-payer health care is a
more socialist policy than private
market based health care but that
doesn't mean that single-payer is the
most socialist health care policy one
could dream up northern any country that
uses such a system is de facto socialist
along these axes we can determine
whether policies are more or less
socialist okay this is a fair argument
it's also not the argument she was
making she was not making the argument
that we ought to have a more socialist
well a health care system and lots of
people have made that argument and I've
explained why I think that argument is
wrong she was arguing that capitalism
wholesale should be junked that's a very
different argument but let's take her
new argument let's pretend that this was
the original argument she made and she's
not
and let's ignore the fact that she's
surrounding herself right that she
actually is pretending that she wrote
something she didn't but what we're
gonna get to her new favorites paradise
it's her socialist paradise in Norway
but for for you to get all of the scoop
on Norway plus we're gonna talk about
Oprah and a lot of other stuff you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire.com
and subscribe so for just $9.99 a month
you can get a subscription to daily
wire.com that means get the rest of this
show live the rest of the Andrew Klavan
show live there are some Michael Mills
show live it means you get all of those
aforementioned goiters plus you get to
ask me questions personally and that
means that Tuesday March 13 that is
tomorrow okay we are having another
episode of the conversation 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific you get to ask
me questions so here's how it works my
conversation will stream live on the
bench Pierrot Facebook page and the
daily wire YouTube channel it will be
free for everyone to watch only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber log in to our
website over at daily where to come head
over to the conversation page and watch
the live stream after that just start
typing into the daily wired chat box and
I will answer questions as they come in
for an entire hour once again subscribe
to have your questions answered by me
but in Shapiro Tuesday March 13 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific and join
the conversation and ask questions if
you are a subscriber so now please go
subscribe by the way it also does help
us bring you the show in live and live
in color when you subscribe it helps us
run the website it is only on your
support that we can make our business
work so please go over and subscribe
also get the annual subscription rather
than the monthly it's better and also
you get this the leftist here's how to
record tumblr the greatest tumblr in all
of human history so go check that out
with your annual subscription you want
to listen later for free iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe
please leave a serve you it always helps
us we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
all righty so back to this column in The
Washington Post in which someone is
arguing Elizabeth burning is arguing for
socialism so what kind of socialism does
she want she says not Soviet Union not
Venezuela not Cuba not Sweden not
Denmark no Norway okay so we finally
found the country she likes and it is
Norway sure it's really cold in the food
stinks but Norway okay why Norway
because quote as of 2015 Norway owned
roughly 59% of the country's wealth by
contrast China which is still considered
at least a quasi communist state by many
own 32 percent of its national wealth in
Norway government owns home about a
third of the stock market along with 70%
of business 70 businesses valued at
almost 90 percent of the nation's GDP
taken together this means the people of
the Nordic states have come a long way
towards democratizing ownership
dispersing wealth lowering inequality
and placing workers lives under their
own control in other words the socialism
of the Nordic state seems pretty close
to the kind of socialism that I wrote
would satisfy me well that actually
isn't what you wrote but now you're
writing it so we'll take your argument
now and pretend that you wrote it before
okay let's talk about Norway so a few
things about normally first Norway has
no people
hey Norway is 5.6 million people the
County of Los Angeles is 3 point 9
million people hey there are no people
in Norway so it's kind of easier to do
redistribution when you have no people
and also in enormous oil industry the
oil industry which was nationalized
understand in Norway in the 1960s ok the
oil industry is responsible for fully 22
percent of the GDP of Norway they've a
trillion dollar state fund that is
completely funded by oil wealth and 67
percent of all exports from Norway are
an oil and natural gas so it's more like
the United Arab Emirates than it is like
the United States all right it's a giant
oil plutocracy in which everyone is in
plutocrat because you have five people
and lots of oil ok it's a lot like the
UAE and in fact when you look at
countries by by GDP per capita what you
see is that this is not uncommon right
GDP per capita according to the
according to the the according to our
friends over at doctor Wikipedia it's
countries like Qatar Qatar is the number
one country in GDP per capita because
it's an oil emirate right 125 thousand
dollars per person now would you rather
live there yeah United Arab Emirates
right it's 68 thousand dollars per
person
the United States is $59,000
per person where would you rather live
the answer is the United States because
we have this thing called freedom it
turns out that when you give a lot of
power to the government then sometimes
they can give you a lot of money based
on the exports of oil but it's hard to
actually have freedom to rise in these
societies ok the oil industry represents
approximately 22% of Norway's GDP and
two-thirds of their exports and pays for
36 percent of the national governments
revenue so it is because of oil they're
allowed to survive hey and that's not
the extent of their government holdings
the government also seized all German
own stocks after World War two so after
World War 2 Norway just seized all of
the stocks and they nationalize them
which explains the state's high levels
of ownership in the stock market but
does this mean that the state runs the
businesses for the benefit of the
workers do they run the benefits do they
run the businesses in full Marxist
fashion where they're just deciding
based on the women to the workers vote
no the stockholders vote okay in fact
Norway insists that all of its business
run according to the whims of
stockholders and all stockholders must
be chosen equally in fact in Norway
state-owned industries do something that
doesn't happen in the United States
state-owned industries in the United in
Norway can actually go bankrupt that's
actually happened before so the state
actually operates more like mercantilist
18th century Britain with regard to for
example the the Royal trading companies
then it does like then it does like the
Soviet Union or Cuba or among Marxist
lines and Norway's a relatively friendly
business climate for people who are
looking to set up a business Heritage
Foundation ranks to 23rd in the world
the United States ranks about 18th now
again it is important to recognize that
also the redistributionist tendencies of
Norway and it's workable economy are
partially a result of the people who
live there ok culture matters Norway has
a different culture in fact Norway's
culture is pretty easy to spot you know
how you can tell when Norway has a
different culture as opposed to other
countries number one there's almost no
diversity in Norway ok nor only 13% of
people who live in Norway are immigrants
and only 15% 6% of the population are
immigrants are children of immigrants ok
32% of the population of Norway has a
higher education degree so if we're
gonna actually compare Norway to the
United States you want to compare apples
to apples so how do we do that we
compare Norwegians in Norway with
Norwegians in the United States and
here's a dirty little fact Norwegians in
the United States earn more than
Norwegians in Norway this is also true
of Danish folks living in the United
States and Swedish Americans buy Danish
Americans
according to NEMA suntan G she says or
he says rather that Danish Americans
have a 55% higher living standard
maintains themselves Swedish Americans
have a 53% higher living standard than
Swedes the gap is even greater 59
percent between Finnish Americans and
Finns so if you come over here from your
home country of Norway you're gonna do
better in the United States than you
were doing in Norway even Norwegians
emit Norwegian Americans who don't have
the oil wealth redistribution of soil
wealth of Norway they have a 3% higher
living standard than their cousins
overseas so that's statistic about
higher per capita GDP it doesn't make as
much of a difference as you would think
okay June Norway has about seventy one
thousand dollars per year per capita 59
thousand five hundred and eight but
again a lot of that's due to oil wealth
and the top personal income tax rate in
Norway is 48 percent the corporate tax
rate is 25% the tax burden in Norway
represents thirty eight point one
percent of total domestic income
compared to twenty six percent in the
United States government spending
amounts to forty eight point six percent
of GDP GDP compared to thirty eight
percent in the United States and it is
super expensive to live in Norway this
is the thing that people neglect about
all the socialist Swedish in or Norway
all these countries the Nordic countries
is really expensive to live there a
haircut can cost you 50 bucks in Norway
now I may pay 50 bucks for a haircut but
that's because I'm a professional person
on television okay there is no super
cuts for $8.00 in Norway it is the
second most expensive country to buy
food in Europe which means it is the
food on planet Earth it is the most
expensive country to buy alcohol and
tobacco vehicles cost forty to fifty
percent more in Norway than they do in
the United States food costs like 60%
more than it does in the United States
and by the way they're running out of
money despite all of this all of this
oil wealth they are realizing that
eventually the oil wealth will run out
and that's why they elected a
Conservative government not a liberal
government a Conservative government in
2013 and reelected that government in
2017 okay's Norway may be more
socialistic than the United States but
it is certainly not a paradise and the
notion that we are going to base all of
this that we're gonna we're gonna become
Norway is just so ignorant on every
level that the revealer I have to
imagine the only reason Elizabeth
verdict spit out Norway as opposed to
Denmark or Sweden is that she recognized
that was kind of right on time marking
Sweden so she picked another Nordic
country to talk about ok so mean
while President Trump over the weekend
had another one of his another one of
his speeches and this speech was a wild
hootenanny I mean a wild hootenanny so
the President of the United States led
off by explaining what his 2020 slogan
it would be when we start running in can
you believe it two years from now is
going to be Keep America great
exclamation point
Keep America exclamation point okay now
like Jeb exclamation point is gonna keep
America great explanation why because
America wasn't great before Trump was
elected but now it's great and so we're
gonna keep it great okay fair enough the
guy's got a nose for marketing can't
can't really blame on that one
the left will go predictably nuts over
all that that wasn't what made all the
headlines though what really made all
the headlines that Trump decided to go
after a bunch of other political figures
from one of those political figures he
decided to go after was of course Maxine
Waters Maxine Waters is indeed a non
intelligent person we've talked about
Maxine Waters many times on the show
before Maxine Waters someone who's
called the Los Angeles Riots the LA
uprising ok the Los Angeles Riots were
on not prising it was a bunch of people
in inner-city south central burning down
inner-city South Central is not an
uprising it was a riot Maxine Waters
said in 2004 Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
were doing just fine she tried to get a
bailout for I have it was blue I believe
is her husband's or her brothers bank
one United my Maxine Waters is not I
mean you can watch listen I've been very
clear that I don't think the Trump is
exactly Phi Beta Kappa okay I'm pretty
clear what I think politicians are not
all that smart
okay Maxine Waters is not a smart person
Trump says this though and people call
them racist Maxine Waters a very low IQ
individual never see him you ever seen
it you ever seen we will impeach him we
will impeach the press but he hasn't
done anything wrong
it doesn't matter we will impeach him
she's a low IQ individual you can't help
okay so people call them racist because
he was in is someone who's jon favreau
from the Obama campaign uh who's now on
pot save America oh this is racist he
went to a white rural part of
Pennsylvania and he said a black person
stupid that's racist he cruises a lot
some people are stupid maybe watch this
guy he's called he's called people
though IQ before he says people are
stupid on a regular basis like this is
not a shock and also Maxine Waters is
kind of dumb yeah just putting it out
there like there are lots of there are
lots of black legislators who are not
dumb Kamala Harris is a smart person
Barack Obama was an intelligent person
Cory Booker for as much that it's like
him is a relatively smart person Maxine
Waters is he dumb dumb hey Maxine Waters
is a fruit loop and so Trump calling or
calling her a dumb dumb is is just that
is not racist then he attacked the media
because this is what Trump does you know
when once he gets going it's a comedy
routine and so he goes after Chuck Todd
in some rather colorful language here
here here we go
never see the story where I'm it's 1999
I'm on Meet the Press a show now headed
by sleepy eyes Chuck Todd he's a
sleeping son of a shell Talia
yeah it's kind of weird it's a Chuck
Todd apparently is a sleepy eyed sob
which is which is pretty spectacular and
then Chuck Todd responds again here's
the thing about Trump is this stuff the
president should be saying no of course
not I don't remember George Washington
calling Thomas Jefferson a sleepy eyed
son of a like that was not that
was not a thing like Abraham Lincoln was
not gonna uh you know that Jefferson
Davis that sleepy-eyed son of a
it wasn't thing let alone members of the
media but yeah you know it's a thing
Trump does we're all used to it by now
but what makes it ridiculous is that
people in the media are still trying to
schoolmarm him so what they really
should say is listen the presidents of
the United States we understand he's
having a tough time out there in the
approval ratings but you know not
appropriate language but instead they
decided to go completely over the top so
as somebody who's been called every name
in the book by pretty much everyone I
mean there was a full op-ed in the New
York Times like not that long ago what
was it four months ago by by a
particularly columnist suggesting that I
was not as courageous as I think I am
that I was sort of a coward in some way
that columnist and I regularly
correspond now okay so I like so this is
the fact that you know that people are
mean to members of the media the members
of the media can't take it there are
some pretty thin skinned members of the
media here is Chuck Todd's response and
after all of this many people including
myself raised their kids to respect the
office of the presidency and the
president United States when he uses
vulgarity to talk about individuals what
are they supposed to tell their kids I
don't know Chuck what are you supposed
to tell your kids you know what I tell
my kids he's a jerk right that's what I
would tell my kids and my kid asked me
if my daughter asked me why are people
mean you dad I would say because they're
jerks and that'd be the end of the
conversation okay this is sort of school
arming and tutting all of this combined
with the leftist radicalism none of this
is going to hurt Trump in fact all of it
is probably going to help Trump okay so
and now I want to discuss the latest on
Trump North Korea and and all the rest
so President Trump at this rally in
Pennsylvania he came out and discussed
his upcoming meeting with Kim jong-un so
last Friday he sort of flip-flopped
there was a there was a statement that
he wanted preconditions to me with kim
jeong-hoon
he want the the dictator of North Korea
that he only wanted to meet with him if
there were certain conditions met and
then the White House
walked that back and said we don't want
precondition
a lot of this is about Trump's faith and
himself as a negotiator
a lot of this is Trump thinks that he
can walk in a room and get the old stone
now this is completely ignorant okay
Trump is not a great negotiator the last
time he negotiated a deal it was a deal
that involved Nancy Pelosi instruction
when walking in on the budget and
walking out with exactly what they
wanted but Trump thinks he's a great
negotiator and so here he is talking at
his rally about meeting with kim
jeong-hoon he says I'm the only guy who
can make this deal happen they announced
that he's not going to send missiles up
anymore until through the meetings well
think of that you know we were losing
getting a lot of missiles sent
I wouldn't say Japan was thrilled
missiles flying over Japan they're very
happy with what I'm doing
and who else could do it
I mean honestly when you think they're
not gonna send missiles up think of it
okay so again if this is the big
concession that they're not gonna fire
missiles for like six weeks until they
meet that's not a concession and who
else can do it anyone Jimmy Carter could
do it Bill Clinton could do it George W
Bush could do it if you want to meet
with bad guys without preconditions it's
not all that hard I don't have a lot of
faith in Trump's negotiation skills with
regards in the North Koreans I really
don't I don't think he's gonna walk in
the room and then come out of the room
with a big deal from the North Koreans I
explained why last week but that said it
is funny to watch people on the left
fulminate over this Ben Rhodes
particularly Ben Rhodes is the worst
human being Ben Rhodes the the former
national security adviser to try to
Obama whose entire job description
before that consisted of writing
unpublished novels from his Brooklyn
apartment I hands up being the the
instigator of the or Anzio allowing the
United States to basically surrender
regional sovereignty to Iran like here
he is hunting Trump over the North
Korean media now listen I'm not in favor
than a North Korean meeting but I'm not
gonna hear it from idiots like that
Rhodes well the concern I have is look
this is not a real-estate deal or a
reality show when you're in a
negotiation with something as complex as
a North Korean nuclear program and a
situation that is volatile as a Korean
Peninsula you need diplomats so advice
one is don't hollow out the State
Department they have no ambassador to
Seoul the person who was in charge of
North Korea negotiations just left the
State Department so one get the
professionals in the room to put
together a strategy okay you mean the
professionals in the room like the
people you sent in to give a billion
dollars in
cash to the Iranians like that those
people like on palates and the people
who who you sense in the room to give
the Iranians everything they could ever
want including regional control over
large swaths of Iraq and Syria and
Lebanon those people again I'm not in
favor of Trump meeting here howling he's
gonna do any better than Obama did on
North Korea but I do think that the the
Obama people tut-tutting Trump for doing
exactly the same thing Obama would have
done is is ridiculous and crazy okay
time for some things I like and then
some things I hate and we'll do a quick
Federalist paper so things that I like
so speaking of socialism so this week
we're going to talk a little bit about
socialism for the educational is it
burning over at the Washington Post okay
there's a great book called the road to
Wigan Pier by George Orwell is what well
worth the read this is one of our Welles
lesser read at Cowell lesser read books
actually
and the basic book I was about socialism
in Britain and so the first half of the
book is about mass unemployment in in
north of England and the poverty that he
sees there but the second half of the
book is about how state control is not
the answer and that's one of the things
that's really interesting about Orwell
is Orwell certainly saw what was driving
so much of the ire against capitalism
but he also recognized the dangers of
socialism another one of his books that
I that I love very much as is a homage
to Catalonia which is totally worth
reading a lot of the books that he wrote
that are nonfiction are actually better
books and then then then the books that
he wrote that are fiction so you should
check out homage to Catalonia you should
also check out the road to Wigan Pier
both of those are really fascinating
books and what with reading plus he's
just a great writer his writing really
leaps off the page there's so many
classic books that don't read like
classics and Orwell's really do okay
time for let you know let's do a bunch
of things I hate let's just hate on a
bunch of crap today
okay so Oh Jake and OJ had a confession
like and if I did a confession that is
from ten years ago I remember when this
first came out Ashley it's 15 years ago
now and there's such hubbub because
people are saying why should a J be
getting TV time to basically confess for
a crime we all know he did well finally
that tape came out it was broadcast
yesterday on Fox here's what it looked
like this guy kind of got into a karate
thing and I said well you think you can
kick my ass and I remember I grabbed the
knife I do remember that portion taking
the knife from Charlie and to be honest
after that I don't remember
except I'm standing there and it's all
kind of stuff around and what kind of
stuff but stuff around no I'm in the
back of it still in the back of the
truck and I can't believe what I'm
seeing
because as every time we go by
intersections it was like where did
these people get the time to make these
signs go old J and stuff and what was
strange is is is is I had been I was
being depicted as a fugitive on the
radio but from the side of the roads it
was more people cheering I just remember
listening to the radio which think was
dan Rather it really saved my life right
because when he said that OJ had a
history police were at their house all
the time at eight or nine times that
that was the first time that week that I
kind of woke up hey man I said what they
said about me they see this is this
interview is the interviewer sitting
there going wait what's going on now
so there's OJ basically confessing to
murder yes of course Oh J murdered his
ex-wife as well as Ronald Goldman of
course he murdered those people and of
course it was during nullification and
the fact that the polls show that a
large percentage of black folks in
America at the time the OJ trials
thought that he was innocent just shows
that human beings generally not just
black folks human beings generally have
an enormous capacity for cognitive
failure right well I'm talking about
failure to to accept cognitive
dissonance that you you don't like the
the racial politics may not be what you
like but oshiage isms and did in fact
kill his ex-wife it's just okay evidence
folks evidence seven and seven and so J
was guilty obviously okay other things
that I hate so Oprah Winfrey just calls
me she
just calls me and now she you know she's
she's kind of making overtures to her
maybe I'll run my favorite thing is that
she said that if God tells her to run
that maybe she'll run now I like that
the women of the view were very angry my
pence whenever he talked about God
talking to him but when Oprah says it
suddenly there's an actual pipeline to
to God here's Oprah Winfrey talking
about the herd all of her kind of fake
religious nonsense her spiritual but not
religious nonsense just drives me up a
wall here she was talking to to the
audience about how to survive Trump's
America be a warrior of the light I
think I have to just say please
everybody is feeding yourself on the
hysteria and the negativity you've gotta
stay in the light but one of the reasons
why I was so excited is about a wrinkle
in time because the message is that the
darkness is spreading so fast these days
you must become a warrior of the light
okay I don't even know what that means I
don't even know what that means you got
to be a warrior of the light okay what
are you even talking about then it gets
even bigger and more dumb okay so she
said this one last week and I really
wanted to play it and I just forgot
about it this is where she's talking to
a young girl what's her advice to young
girls this is the most subjectivist
nonsense oh yeah okay here she goes I
have that advice for girls who look like
you and for girls who don't because the
advice is really the same the the
highest honor on earth that you will
ever have is the honor of being yourself
and your only job in the world is to
figure out that's what this movie is
about your only job in the world people
think your job is to get up and go and
raise money and take care of your family
and stuff that that's an obligation that
you have but your only true job is a
human being is to discover why you can't
okay this is the most subjective
nonsense postmodernist crap okay if your
only job in the world is to discover
yourself and to be yourself my baby just
did it okay like this is it your job in
the world is to better yourself your job
in the world is to be moral there are
certain moral demands that are made upon
you by God and nature is by nature and
nature's God
okay that's your job to fulfill those
things your obligations exist outside of
you your obligations are not only to
yourself and if you believe that all of
morality can be found within you and
that all of all you have to do is
fulfill what you feel and then
everything will be great this is how you
end up with a solid Cystic nihilistic
sasai
no one has anything in common because we
all have our own mission in the world
and those missions often conflict with
one another but were the only people in
the end who really matter I hate this
stuff more than I can tell you this
Nouveau is this Nouveau garbage just
yeah okay fine
now Federalist paper number 19 good news
this will take me 30 seconds because
it's a very it's a very historically
based Federalist Papers so Federalist
paper number 19 Alexander Hamilton and
James Madison writing they consider
talking about why the Articles of they
are still considering about why the
Articles of Confederation were
insufficient to preserve the Union they
give a couple of examples as to why
loose Confederations have failed in the
past they explore the situation's of
Germany pre Bismarck is obvious they're
living pre Bismarck and and the Polish
Confederation and the Swiss
Confederation in short long story short
they essentially say all of these places
have made themselves vulnerable to
foreign invasion and have suffered from
severe internal warfare as well and
that's why we need a stronger
centralized government boom done with
Federalist number 19 in 30 seconds or
left so it's less so we will be back
here tomorrow with the breakdown of
everything that's going on apparently
President Trump proposing a new quasi
gun control bill or at least something
to do with parkland we'll analyze it in
all of its details I'm Ben Shapiro
there's the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018